un million 636 200 euros la cagnotte
controversée en faveur du policier qui a
tué le jeune Naël a fermé hier soir à
minuit une démarche souhaitée par son
initiateur Jean Messia ancien
porte-parole de l'eczemmour contre qui
la famille du jeune adolescent a porté
plainte pour escroquerie et détournement
les bras chargés de vêtements
ou de produits cosmétiques ils sont fut
en courant
leur cible privilégiée les boutiques de
luxe
les magasins de chaussures comme cette
célèbre marque de sport et les
téléphones portables dernier cri
un butin amassé ses derniers jours que
les pilleurs cherchent à présent à
écouler sur internet le nouvel iPhone 12
est à reconnaissance anale ah c'est ma
femme ouais mon cœur parce que vous
voulez être le premier prévenu dès qu'un
appel entre c'est le bureau excuse-moi
oui Pascal n'hésitez pas à nous
contacter on a beaucoup de stocks volés
à écouler on peut pas tout mettre ici
sur les plateformes des annonces sont
aussi suspectes ici ces téléphones de
luxe quasi neuf sont à prix cassés
sur cette autre site ces profils
proposent les mêmes choses sur avec la
même photo celle-ci sont toutes à 41
euros seul la pointure diffère pour
certains syndicats de police difficile
de ne pas faire le parallèle avec le
pillage de magasin la semaine dernière
on a du coup des revendeurs des
revendeurs qui aujourd'hui sont les
opportunités qui aujourd'hui ont
l'intention de récupérer rapidement des
marges conséquentes d'argent au moment
des produits qu'ils ont volé moi
j'aimerais bien avoir un de ces guignol
devant moi là un de ces guignols devant
moi pour y mettre une grande plaque vite
faire une simple recherche sur Google
pour voir que rien que la photo du
profil est fausse par exemple là donc je
l'ai agrandi je l'ai mis sur Google et
on voit qu'elle vient d'inciter étranger
où il y a plein de photos d'une fille
inconnue qui a été reprise pour faire ce
compte donc c'est absolument une photo
volée
avec leurs chaussures Nike là leur
petite leur petite comment leur petites
veste leur petit machin les scooters on
met les casques ont fait une roue
personne ils ont aucune interdiction des
coups de pompes dans la tronche et puis
si tu peux pas payer plus d'un autre
pure façon les allocations familiales
toutes ces choses qui sont dues qui sont
dus mais c'est dur bah pourquoi on irait
travailler on a un système où
effectivement il est droit ne sont pas
compensés par des devoirs et
effectivement à partir du moment où
l'État donne quelque chose il y a des
devoirs à exiger en échange et on peut
pas donner des allocations familiales et
ne rien exiger en responsabilité
parentale et s'il y a des carences
éducatives qui sont établies si
effectivement il y a un défaut
d'éducation il faut effectivement à mon
avis sanctionner et notamment aller
jusqu'à privé effectivement
d'allocations familiale c'est familiales
moi j'étais fier d'être français je vais
vous dire mon traiteur je vais arrêter
et puis je vais partir loin je vais
peut-être aller en Irlande en des coches
resterai pas en France moi je laisse la
France à tous ces individus merdiques
qui casse tout qui détruisent tout parce
qu'il y en a marre on était les
meilleurs on était les plus beaux on
était on avait un pays d'accueil de
tourisme et tout vous avez vu là les
restaurateurs comment ils vont faire là
les gens ils rigolent ils viendront pas
en France il viendront pas en France et
c'est pour retrouver leur bagnole brûlés
ou quoi que ce soit il faut dans la vie
vous savez moi j'ai tendance à beaucoup
dédramatiser et malheureusement vu une
époque où les gens surtout les
journalistes les médias dramatissent
tout c'est la fin du monde c'était
épouvantable on va tous mourir non il
faut dédramatiser il faut prendre des
choses avec un petit peu plus de recul
vous nous faites du bien avant d'aller
le but du gouvernement est désormais de
rétablir l'ordre le ministre des
Finances français Bruno Le Maire est
avec nous en directe depuis Paris le
regard grave Bruno Le Maire a voulu
rassurer touriste et amortisseurs en
anglais dans le texte i want to be very
solide grosse is solide and the deadly
life of French citizen is not strange
les jeunes déjà de manière générale ne
veulent plus bosser c'est bien connu
coréen encore moins le gouvernement
proposait gentiment à la population de
passer de 52 heures de travail
hebdomadaire à 69 et quoi ils ont dit
non bon mars dernier ils sont ils ont
enflammé les réseaux sociaux ils sont
des descendues en masse dans la rue le
gouvernement a tenté de maintenir sa
réforme elle est nécessaire pour
répondre au pic d’activité que le pays
connaît acclamé le ministre du Travail
je porte tout le temps même si il y en a
certains qui pensent que c'est lié que
ça ne doit pas
on n'est pas que la praline de toute
manière pour faire le ménage il faut pas
être sur son 41 le Grand Seigneur avait
aussi proposé d'instituer une pause
obligatoire de 11 heures entre deux
journées de travail mais rien n'y a fait
face à la fureur des jeunes le
gouvernement a dû retirer sa réforme
c'est un camouflé pour le président
younsukiol avait déclaré avant d'être
élu être favorable à ce que les gens
puissent travailler 120 heures par
semaine si nécessaire ah oui mais Saoud
transporte 100 kg de poissons sans aucun
moyen de conservation
à cause d'une crevaison il a dû
s'arrêter de rouler une nuit entière
alors ce matin il garde le pied sur
l'accélérateur
la fraîcheur des poissons passe avant le
confort des passagers
[Musique]
bref en un mot les jeunes ne veulent
plus ressembler à leurs parents ils
veulent avoir du temps pour eux pour
aimer pour vivre pour faire l'amour et
ils ont d'ailleurs un argument Massu
pour convaincre le reste de la
population l'argument assez logique
quand on y pense continuer à travailler
plus c'est se reproduire toujours moins
et ça la Corée ne peut pas se le
permettre le pays a atteint le taux de
natalité catastrophique de 0,78 enfant
par femme les enfants ce sont les
travailleurs de demain un très bon
slogan pour une campagne électorale
l'INSEE vient de publier le classement
officiel des prénoms les plus donnés aux
nouveaux-nés en 2022 et cette année
encore on félicite les petites Jade et
les petits Gabriels qui conservent la
tête du classement peu de bouleversement
d'ailleurs dans le top 10 alors chez les
filles Jade et donc en tête devant
Louise et Ambre ambre qui chipe la
troisième place à Emma et Alba et
quatrième là où certains cherchent le
classique le rétro d'autres cherche
l'originalité en salle des naissances
cette sage-femme a parfois eu quelques
surprises j'ai déjà eu un Johnny avec un
dé devant pour faire bien Johnny donc ça
c'était rigolo on a déjà eu aussi garçon
fille c'était Mégane et Renaud c'est
vraiment quelque chose d'identitaire
entre guillemets et c'est aussi pour ça
que certains s'amusent même à jouer avec
avec les prénoms chez les garçons le
podium n'a pas bougé Gabriel Léo et
Raphaël ont prouvent ensuite dans le top
10 Louis Noah Jules Arthur Adam Lucas en
fait dans le top 100 les grandes
tendances ne bougent pas cette année
prime au prénom court 4 ou 5 lettres
maximum avec une préférence pour ceux
qui se terminent par la lettre A le ciel
dépêche-toi s'il te plaît on va être en
retard je vais faire enlever par la
script parce qu'on a une script qui nous
dit attention c'est trop long ça déborde
etc donc je me tais merci d'avoir chanté
pour moi en tout cas Thomas à très
bientôt